titanfall 2 has a brand new one on one  mode called Coliseum but you might not  be getting in without a little snack I'm  Tony and this is your carbonated  gamespot news update coliseum mode pits  two players against each other in a  best-of-three competition but to enter  the coliseum you need a ticket these are  available on specially marked Mountain  Dew drinks and doritos bags the ticket  will get you into the coliseum plus get  you double XP and the chance to win  special Titan customization items each  ticket is only good for one go in the  Coliseum but we reached out to respond  to see if there are other ways to get  them titanfall 2 comes to ps4 xbox one  and pc on october 28th developer respawn  has also released the games pc  requirements so you can head over to  gamespot to check those out and for all  the biggest titanfall 2 News you're  already in the right place  you